the man from the PRU may prudential a
household name in the UK but the insurer
has changed out of all proportion since
then and now with technological and
product changes and huge overseas
expansion it's decided to break itself
into the fund management arm M&G along
with its UK and European operations will
form one business its operations in the
US Asia and Africa the other they'll
both be London listed companies and in
the footsie 100 I spoke to the chief
exactly it might Wells a little earlier
and asked him why because the businesses
have got to a position of size and
strength where we think they're better
off as two independent corporations the
the the the growth and success of the UK
business the growth and success of the
US and Asia business you know they have
less in common and and we think there's
a chance to unlock value and to improve
the lie of most of our stakeholders how
should investors look at the
newly-formed M&G prudential it's going
to be a business that bears more
comparison with the likes of Aviva and
legal in general or over time do you see
it becoming a specialist fund manager
like standard aberdeen investors well i
it has some similarities with each of
those firms I'd like to think the best
of each of them it's got a very
successful asset management business in
the active space not passive and isn't
lacking any portfolios so there's no you
know we're not doing this to again to
fill any sort of need it's got the most
successful with profits fund in the
country it's got very successful
distribution in Europe it's got very
successful with profits look which again
is a fairly unique attribute to those
firms so it's not analogous to any of
them we think it has very very high
quality earnings it competes with a
number of those firms you know for the
the the discretionary savings dollar
here in the UK and then to some of them
in Europe but we can we compete pretty
effectively with them they're good firms
but but we think we have the
capabilities to to win here and the
newly-formed prudential plc the
international part of the business for
how long is that going to remain London
listed and London headquarters when
after all its activities are going to be
elsewhere in the world yeah it's true
but I think the
in the Senate it's true the activities
or elsewhere in the world it's not
necessarily true that the headquarters
needs to be anywhere else
following the logic of this breakup
though wouldn't it also be logical to
separate the new Prudential plc in two
separate American and Asian constituents
I mean after all those two markets don't
have an awful lot in common the Asian
market is very fast-growing full of
young people entering the workforce
whereas the American market by contrast
you've got I think you were saying today
10,000 people retiring every day for the
next 20 years yeah I feel like some days
and I can name them it's a we do focus
on them mentally and and and there are
key parts the largest wealth transfer
and that you know globally in history
and the baby boomers and and
disproportionately more that in the
front ten years or so of that period of
time the the to your point the
diversification across ages helps but
it's so that's that's good from a risk
reduction as our different exposure to
credits markets currencies and things
although most these markets are
disproportionately dollar denominated
the the I think the piece of Asia that
is coming next so what we've been
working on the last few years is to
increase the size of our health business
and health and Asia has more of a
wellness flavor to it than just pure
health insurance but that's over a
billion pounds now in last year's
earnings which is growing really nicely
I think we would be foolish to ignore
the coming retirement needs a lot of
these Asian economy is gonna grow old
before they grow rich I think it's a
real challenge I mean one of the things
you hear on the ground in a lot of
countries in Asia is the traditional
retirement model was young younger
member usually children's adult children
taking care of senior members of the
family and as families have gotten
smaller in Asia for a variety of reasons
that model is stressed so you know I
talked to young people that are worried
about how they're gonna help fund their
parents retirement I talked to people
who are about to retire who worry about
how their children are you know
contribute to the retirement or help
fund it and it seemed more like you're
seeing here in the UK or the US where
people are feeling you know they're
responsible for funding their own
retirement and what do you think about
stock markets at the moment we obviously
had a shakeout
around the world last month we've had a
bit of a recovery since then but should
we really expect stellar returns after
the what we've seen over the last few
years well it feels to me this is a bit
self-serving but it's more of an active
market than a passive market you know I
think it's individual companies now you
know the the you know the easy gains
from the low interest rates and
companies refinancing are done you know
rising rates help some companies and
hurt others you know and I think now
it's more name by name than just just
the overall market going up or down but
I think there's plenty of opportunity